[Musik]
muskeln und kraft als statussymbole
junge menschen zelebrieren den
körperkult wie selten zuvor
[Musik]
ja deine fitness die wand ist revier
machtkampf er wirklich liegt besser
ausgesetzt da und reden
außerdem wird wieder rauer see wurde
auch der ganzen szene im schnitt
schlacht sehr viel besser geworden oder
verantworten
und ich muss noch rasch ausfindig
kennedy muss sie noch nie verbessere und
der buch muss ja noch les oder
definitionen schaffen
[Musik]
jenny die pfeiler ist eine art
bildhauerin am eigenen körper mit
leidenschaft modelliert sie schultern po
und bauch und tattoos sollen das
gesamtbild abrunden
das kunstwerk ist fast zweijähriger ihre
namen körperformen du natürlich fis und
der durch die sanität und körper
bestattung zu mir gehört das ist
wirklich großes von kunstwerken scott
mit tätowierungen sind in der kraftsport
szene angesagt diego lattmann kann sich
jedenfalls nicht über mangelnde aufträge
beklagen ich mal ein spiel zwischen dem
tv großen buseck ist ja genau
wissenschaft balance board aus was ich
mache mit nur grosse und mache zu
anderen erst morgen heute arbeitet er an
ihrem 24
das gerät ist bedeutet für mich
telefonisch oder wie zum beispiel marie
womit zum beispiel projekt heißt stärke
und willig windstärke kürze mir gemacht
verschafft statt 2 steht für bitte sehr
gut aus
[Musik]
fortschritt gemacht haben
es klopft an
[Musik]
so gern dass die juden seine
leidenschaft gemacht gehen und erst am
morgen ja aber ich mache 78 wohlfühlen
so glücklich bin macht es mir spaß macht
[Musik]
das baby ist praktisch
kern der sammlung von moosburg satellit
als alle anderen
[Musik]
es macht spaß und freude am auto es ist
hobby von mir als teenager gehörte
miguel bieger zu jenem fünfte junge
menschen in der schweiz die
übergewichtig sind erachte buch kamera
und klasse und das geschäft von noras
sagen ja und dann haben die kanzel wurde
und dann alfred eder guten einschnitte
buchloes werde sei es nur um das gaben
waffen um minderwertigkeitskomplex
losrennen im jahren ja wahrscheinlich
kübelweise ergänzungs nahrung sollen ihm
zusätzlich helfen sicherheitskraft paket
zu positionieren
doch jetzt da 120 km/h flug kann so was
ist das hier war es gut
das protein ja schon zu ist kolle grad
vor der pause flog und proteine von
protein pulver und fritz kramer heidel
berliner dann mache ich das ganze mit
wasser und mit wasser ja sagen wir doch
alle drei wiesen uns dass wieder viel
besser schmecke ich sage jetzt mit dem
joghurt sahne oder rahm mit marga kork
oder so machen aber durch proteinpulver
warnen durch wäre hat das magazin ist
einfach mit versetzen
mit einem stift
und dann nehme ich da noch zehn plätze
omega-3 auch sehr wichtig und schaute
ich mir sehr viel zu stück ist passt das
sind besuchen die fed wo man braucht
frische spuren als ganzes am monitor ist
so viel zusatz richtig stoff braucht ja
danke so um die 300 franken spezia -
vitamintabletten dass proteine
da ihm im zimmer hannes bild der
schweizermeisterschaft verletzt die
herbstmeisterschaft und schweizer
meisterschaft im junioren bodybuilding
grüne
es ist mein erster wettkampf ii und
eintracht erfolg für mich aber jetzt
anders herzen so viel muskeln die man
einfach so die sichtweise know how für
mit anabolika dringen je nachdem ich an
normal paar zusatzpräparate aber ja das
ist ja nur für die wettkämpfe damit sind
sie da nie kontrolliert wurde
wir haben diesen job prüft wurde aber
sie machen nur stichproben und im
internet naja also erstmal smart über
sportarzt walter frey geht davon aus
dass anabolika konsum weit verbreitet
ist
laut einer studie aus lübeck nehmen bis
zu 20 prozent aller hobbysportler das
illegale aufbaupräparate anabolika sind
hoch bekannte medikament natürlich auch
entsprechend schwerin aber wirkliche
hand die schwersten aber wirklich stehe
dass sie kreist zerstört also die
arterie um eine junge wo regelmäßig
anabolika nimmt sind mit risky besold
wie der 67 jährige mauer mit gefahr für
herzinfarkt mitliest bis 40 mit der
gefahr von hirnschlag und plötzlichen
tod da hat sich eine wohl die jugend
anabolika kno hat schweres schwere
rucksack ort so ganz rechtliche lage
illegale aufbaupräparate lehne sie ab
sagt jenny die schüler hier würden die
kochkünste von mutter maddalena
ausreichen
warum und sieht kaum noch ein training
und dazu 106 gramm pulver und 160
ampullen
okay ich bin ich bin privat kirchen vor
dem genie
er brauchte ich vermute so hoch
geschätzt sehr hohen bedarf jedes mal
dass sie für mich bekommen und es
sportlich aussieht aber wenn ich ja mit
mir auf und verschaffte bringt ist nicht
der zeitpunkt so hilft mir wächst
sollte sie eigentlich dass sie so
intensiv sport macht ok ich muss ja
sagen finde ich als lehrer oder als
rente würden nur im ausgang oder unter
uns und trinken und drogen aus der
schule wenn sie den sport konzentrieren
die ich immer eigentlich als sportliches
sie immer so günstig gerade einmal 1600
kalorien pro tag wird sicher mit oxid
wird jetzt das ganze rudel mittagstisch
heißen tasse bier gab es vor allem noch
stunden um noch mal zittern
die erstmals durch stunde später eher
als langsam ist die zweimal zieht und
jetzt hier zweimal zither sind für vorm
training und nach dem training
ja und ich nehme einfach sachen dann mit
für von unten nach oben gehen alles klar
jenny die pfeiler und miguel bieger sind
seit einem jahr ein paar
im plus die polizei in dieburg hat
gesagt 100 gramm reis vor und nachher
sagen gemacht und dann wenn ich habe ein
plus das thema präger jeder andere an rx
plan
sie bewundert ihn weil er junioren
meister im bodybuilding war er liebt sie
wegen ihres aussehens und ihrer
willensstärke millimeter sensible typen
sie will die sache mit acht seite will
ich bin ich doch wie die rockstars
schöne frauen
dass david gym in schlieren ist mit
seinen rund 3000 trainierenden einer der
größten fitness tempel der schweiz
[Musik]
meine
wir sind also zurückgegangen
ich möchte körper von bord
es gibt immer verbesserungsmöglichkeiten
der vorteil bei pizzen die sport
aktivität der 15 bis 19 jährigen nimmt
zwar generell ab aber gleichzeitig
betreiben immer mehr junge menschen
kraftsport so die neueste studie des
bundesamtes für sport david im inhaberin
kathi flaig bestätigt den buben aus was
man ganz klar feststellt ich getrennt
was viele filme junger jetzt der waage
studio findet bewundern
das hat sich mit dem zusammenhang sieht
mayo 21 boom also die optimale schöne
athletischen körper mit sixpack mit
schulden von natürlich auch über youtube
extrem pusht wert und jungen natürlich
stählerne muskeln als modediktat marcel
scherer professor am zürcher institut
für angewandte psychologie untersuchte
wie junge menschen ihre körper
wahrnehmen
daheim ihre jungen um suche gemerkt dass
eigentlich zwei drittel frauen
jugendliche und steht der sie mit ihrem
körper mit make oder betriebliche
jugendliche so das ist oft dick fühlen
und das heimrecht wartet dagegen schied
der zu der gruppe und die männliche
jugendliche die viel dass ich zweiter
muskulös haben wir zusammen mit der
selbstunsicherheit oder umgekehrt wenn
ich selbst ich habe den hang wo er das
positive bild wieso definieren sie sich
so über körper will man schicke
oberfläche
dadurch geht es halt vorurteilen das ist
ja klar
und das gehört einfach dazu dass da sagt
praktisch und es ist für mich sehr
wichtig was ist der springende punkt
muss ich alles sagen muss man so wie
meine sie das nicht aber trainieren kann
erklärt weil sie mir das ist doch mal
eine schöne frau der hatte speziell sich
[Musik]
alessandro ist am bene sagt er verzichte
bewusst auf illegale
muskelaufbaupräparate seinen körper
schöne er nur durch hartes training
[Musik]
fahrer hatte zylinder wie wichtig eine
gehör bekommt heute unter der junge ja
es ist dank heutzutage ist das wichtiger
als frieden wird terroristen jagen und
zu bewundern und wieder möglichst bald
wird es sicher dieser konkurrenz die
kunden und natürlich habe der frau wird
man sehr gut auch weil die frau sich
nicht wie zu tag sei das ganze fitness
szene und macht dann ist schlagbar start
der frauen insgesamt ich heiße die maria
sie wiedersehen mit christof baum
goalietrainer beim grasshopper club
zürich vor drei jahren endete die
vielversprechende fußball karriere von
alessandro stamm bene seinen körper
streikte weil er zu viel trainiert hatte
[Musik]
statt
captain zwei jahre lang ich glaube die
fußballspieler von der nazi bin ja schon
immer wurde dann ich selber wieder traf
auch oder anime wieder verletzt
und wer ja das schiff durch studieren
das ganze mit dabei
[Musik]
fußball sei seine erste liebe gewesen
erzählt der 20 jährige aber erst das
krafttraining habe aus ihm einen anderen
menschen gemacht
erfolgreich mit dem lauftraining
angefangen habe bin ich wirklich sehr
unsicher ob sie denn sie nach li und
selbständig natürlich auch immer der
bezug indem sie von ihrer familie
braucht vielleicht wirklich sehr
unsicher 7 und mit viel getraut und
sauber sache zu machen und das leben mit
so einem jahr nach dem start laufe schon
mal gefunden
da sich jenny dittweiler arbeitet selber
als personal trainerin aber jetzt sucht
sie die hilfe eines erfahrenen fitness
coaches ball nun soll ihr helfen ihren
körper zu optimieren und sport kein
lockerer
die 22-jährige wählt zum ersten mal an
einem schönheitswettbewerb für kraft
sportlerinnen teilnehmen fantastisch
natürlich würde sie gerne gewinnen meint
sie aber genauso wichtig seien ihr die
vorbereitungen
for most americans trainingsumfeld meist
ich mache jetzt selbst kneifen so haben
wir lehrer erzieher
das heißt wir werden jetzt normal dass
schlangen
wir werden die mittag weg wodurch chance
die heißt das jetzt dass du selber
ziemlich ungewiss haben du bist sehr gut
auf kurs das klingt als 80 prozent aller
jugendlichen in der schweiz sind
sportlich aktiv
[Musik]
doch längst nicht bei allen geht es um
fitness und gesundheit
beinahe wie eine art ersatzreligion
betreiben immer mehr junge menschen
einen kult um ihren körper
das hätte sicher folgen von modetrend
das entschieden die körperliche schiene
geben mit wichtiger wird und der
modetrend deutlich mehr user eigene
sicher dass die medien gerade
menschliche körper hat sehr dominantes
wurde als zweite ist wirksam kann ich
also mit relativ einfachen mitteln
gestaut und diese aber oft einfach die
richtigen schuhe oder folglich zu und
verteilt das gewicht zu fachgebieten die
investitionen in den wunsch körper
erfordern viel zeit und aufwand so wird
der traum body schnell einmal zu sehen
geben denn instanz das interessiere sie
sich danach so stoss hat jetzt für
radsport es geht will armin hopp ist
sicher dass es ist im klassischen job
natürlich kann ich freunde kollegen eine
familie im kreis wo für mich wichtig ist
und der rechtfertigte sie mir für das
spiel auch so sport ich mache gern
blinken oder ping pong
ja so könnte sie fragt man in der
familie ist an bene wofür alessandro am
meisten energie aufwendet dann ist die
antwort klar für den sport
aber auch sein strikter ernährungsplan
hat oberste priorität
er ist kein brot verzichtet auf öl und
salz ich natürlich aus dem salzburger
das was ich sage ich gern das linie
gesehen also lina sie dem sinn dass es
wirklich sehr zeitlos sieht also
irgendwie ja dass mir wichtig genau
jetzt ein familiengericht das derby
gewinnt ist das eigentlich so stressig
das mini richtig können jetzt noch das
leben hier fertig den strukturen wo sie
sagen also ich sage so fahren sehen es
ist aber dass sich negativ aus durch die
schulzeit als ich einfach die hübsche
pflicht dass leon der struktur genau die
stelle durch einfach die struktur und
die linie die ich habe ibm sehen alles
anderes verhalten mag asoziale züge
aufweisen aber die eltern und seine
beiden schwestern stehen hinter ihm
dass man das ganze suchen am meisten an
die razon billen
nein das mache ich auch weniger gern
aber es muss gemacht hatte ist immer
noch nicht punktgenau morpho 20 uhr
morgens einmal aus der disziplin aber
die in einem spiel spielt
eine app über ernährung liegt ihr genie
die schweizer ihr diätprogramm das hat
eine waffe hat holly droht und ihr könnt
jetzt noch eine 4k noch nicht bei mir
stand ich auf fünf hunde kohlenhydraten
kontrolliert ich war jetzt nutzt krüger
am college linie 20e ist das tun ich
habe kompensieren indem ich nach dem
training immer vollgas ins café am 24
270 kilokalorien im plus weil ich gut
sehr gut
[Musik]
ja ja
das werde ihre drinks rät wieso machen
ist ein echter sport ja ich sage somit
im körper verlangt liegen wir so die
bewegung hat will maria mierscheid
wirklich die samstag im trainieren und
den grund eine million lehre dass man
das leben lernen wir versucht täglich
weniger zu machen aber schlussendlich
ist persönlich aus der schweiz weniger
mache ich gebe dann eigentlich unter
prozent 120 prozent sogar wenn immer
vornehmen ich trainiere ich sage
trainings tor und schießt sich selber
ideen sehen
juni fließen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hat dann ist ein jahreshoch potenzial
ja schon bereit
es gibt nichts neues es macht spaß ich
bin gerne dürfen
das ist bitter
jetzt schaut wenn ich zwei tag nicht im
fitness xing ist pracht komisch für mich
meine wieder laufen
das ist für mich alltag das gehört
einfach zu mir und das gehört dazu und
dann wie die lüge wenn wir zahlen das
sind nicht wichtig wer war mit sport
trieben schütte mir unter anderem die
sogenannte glückshormone aus und das
schafft natürlich glücksgefühl und wie
sie das wieder und wieder habe jetzt das
heißt natürlich nicht dass dann jeder wo
sport treibt nur will er die eu schützt
sport süchtig ist dort zu erörtern eben
dass wir alles andere vergessen und nur
noch für die kunst sport lautet damit
man das gefühl hat und erst recht für
umwelt familie soziales egal ist mir da
ein abstieg in kauf nehmen wenn mutter
für den sport trieben
[Musik]
sie ist eine der bekanntesten fitness
frauen der schweiz anja zeitler
[Musik]
dieses video auf youtube machte sie zum
star
obwohl es nichts mit sport zu tun hat
über 350.000 mal wurde es bis heute
angeklickt
[Musik]
ich bin ein bisschen gut hinaus nehmen
ich denke das ist jetzt aber mit dem
unglück ist ein kind wenn wir zur sache
nicht darum wo ich mit definitiven
branche business und jede machen alle
weiter schlafen und weiter davon träumen
denke ich nicht vom fleck
du musst aufstehen es anpacken und dafür
kämpfen
der gelernten kurs gelang es ihren
bekanntheitsgrad geschickt zu vermarkten
sie realisierte motivation videos und
stellte sie online
dabei verdient sie an der werbung die
youtube ihren videos vor schaltet
schnell wurde anja zeitler zum vorbild
junger fitness begeistert hat
gleichzeitig begann sie im internet
ernährungspläne anzubieten
das geschäft boomt täglich kommen im
schnitt acht neue kunden dazu für eine
beratung verlangt sie über 300 franken
ich habe mich nie geschafft zum training
entdeckt und ich habe jüdische auf die
analytiker und ich heim nachhinein
realisiert
die 22 jährige weiß ich auch als fitness
model zu inszenieren nachgebesserte foto
seiner frau an der nicht alles natur
gewachsen ist
so ließ sich anja zeitler ihre brüste
durch silikon implantate vergrößern
todt aus gezappelt die vergleich von
denen viele terry sogar durch
computerprogramme arbeitet er behütet
vergleichen wir nachher die bilder mit
meldete körper und das kann natürlich
schon diskrepanz natürlich das hätte
negative konsequenzen
zwei befinden auf die psychische
gesundheit abruf physiologische prozesse
des castello zu depressionen schuldig
und sass ag zusammenhang also vom
wohlbefinden positive chartbild unter
psychischen störungen
das ist ja das medizinstudium relativ
groß die obsessive fixierung auf
körperliche maßstäbe führten bei daniel
schläfli in die krankheit schon seit
jahren kämpft die primarlehrerin gegen
ihre essstörung
ursache sei das gefühl den
schönheitsidealen nicht genügen zu
können
danke dass ich mich für alle models hat
eine frau mit flacher büro orientierter
verglichen mit einer frau meistens
verglichene mitglied von
regierungskanzlei kommen schlecht ab ja
das ist so in dieser klinik für frauen
mit essstörungen wurde daniel schläft
wie 2011 wochen lang behandelt
beim eintritt war sie bis auf die
knochen abgemagert
woods will was sind sie dem buch das ist
für mich aber das ist alles und das ist
das was wahrscheinlich ist aber dass das
global gut dass die 22 miss li na ja ich
das jetzt wo sie eigentlich wissen wie
wichtig das war jetzt nicht so dass sie
natürlich wahnsinnig
das ist nicht mein lieblings so gut aber
ich hatte noch nie derart nach in der
kunsttherapie modellierte sie eine
flamencotänzerin mit runden formen
heute geht es ihr wieder besser
rückblickend sei ihr klar was der
auslöser ihrer krankheit war
medici mittagszeit wurde großen schlag
auf schlag hektik oder mindestens
einfach ist unbedingt schlank blieben um
schlussendlich ist nur eine sucht einen
koffer mit 14 jahren
viele der songs einer küste und bei
treffen mit freunden habe sie früher
innerlich stets nur kalorien gezählt
mittlerweile könne sie sich wieder voll
und ganz auf gespräche konzentrieren
sagt die 32 jährige
und das klingt ja warum ich glaube
wirklich klärt auf was wirklich wichtig
ist dass sap nach müssten die stadtwerke
dass die show liefern aber und
investoren österlicher bliebe
michael biegler arbeitet auf eigene
rechnung als maler stellt traumberuf
aber es macht mir spaß dass ich das ohne
client an und die mir waren bin ich
recht zufrieden macht gern mit sport
sauber sind jetzt wählen
ja nein ich bin nicht so der fan vor so
macht lieber für mich ist sport und
jenny als freundin so malte er sich sein
lebensglück aus aber seit kurzem stecken
die beiden in einer beziehungskrise
vor und während der krise mit genannt
das ist richtig dass ich studieren
wieso lisa santos kann dieses verstand
ist kein problem
holly golightly krise
und meine den gelernten beruf als pharma
assistentin hat jenny die schweizer vor
drei jahren an den nagel gehängt
heute arbeitet sie als personal
trainerin
zurzeit bildet sie sich weiter zum
master trainer sind sie angehört aber
mit dem mini kabinett seine gründe
beckum von ich muss nicht nur
vorbereiter und das mir sehr wichtig und
und der zambrano abschlussprüfungen und
ich muss absolvieren und für draußen
[Musik]
was ist das jetzt für sich einnehmen
gross lebe jetzt hand nehme ja ja es ist
sehr schmerzhaft ja da muss auch noch
lila und eine wie ich das für sie ihr
leid
ja es ist ja es ist sicher nicht schön
aber das ist ja ein sehr schönes wort
[Musik]
alles an rustam bene gönnt sich zwei
wochen ferien in süditalien
soeben hat er die lehrabschlussprüfung
als versicherungskaufmann bestanden
er ist auf der suche nach gesunden
nahrungsmitteln
[Musik]
nein ich ein anders thema auslassen und
sport ja es gibt fünf verschiedene
themen wie werden andere jugendliche
meine frau ist aus themar und ja sie
hatten hier nur immerzu es im freien
fall aus der frauen und fitness
ja ich jetzt damit fast so ja der 20
jährige hat sich in einer ferienwohnung
einquartiert er ist mit viel gepäck
angereist
also ich kann wirklich liebt dosen
[Musik]
thunfisch sind nur noch zwei mussten wir
dem wasser
warum das geht ja doch was auch yummy
findet leider nicht immer gesunder ich
sagen wir verkaufen nummer sicher ich
kann nicht immer der fuß dass man das
raw findet und ich hätte nicht
unvorbereitet mit übungen zeitung mit
die müsse was ist also ganz ehrlich nein
also twitter immer irgendwie für mich
als ich finde dass ich den körper
optimal versorgen
alessandro ist nicht alleine hier also
ein sport kollege diego daniele liegt
allerdings mit fieber im bett mit einer
mandelentzündung ist doch jenny die
schwaiger ans bett gebunden
hartes training und strikte diät
schwächten ihr immunsystem
sie nahmen zu wenig mikronährstoffe wie
proteine und kohlenhydrate zu sich
elf kilo will sie abnehmen bis zum
schönheitswettbewerb der in einigen
wochen stattfindet
ich muss mich da zu erzwingen zumal die
haie bleiben will so schlecht ist nur
mit und da bin ich vielleicht noch ein
wochen sondern zwei wochen lang was ich
auf den widerspruch sie waren absolut
fit sie und du darfst welche sie würde
sie nun zu stehen das ist schwachsinn
denn natürlich muss er bringe wo die
körper belastet und es ist klassischen
widerspruch habe natürlich durch diego
kalifornien wo die donau gefahren
natürlich so dass der körper wie sie
sagen fällt und wenn ich zu wenig in 24
das hat natürlich schon bakterien viren
eine schulklasse das immunsystem nicht
zu gehen hat man ab durchaus sportlich
aufgesetzt was heißt das für den körper
das ist sehr sehr gefährliches spiel
gleichzeitig baue man etwas anabol in
der fachsprache bruch dann ein gewisses
fett am körper dass der körper kann aus
dem vollen schöpfen
und wenn jetzt gleichzeitig zwei völlig
gaga leute die den ganzen körper
auslösen und das ist sehr quirlig das
kann zum beispiel sogenannte
übertraining auslösen
das heißt er zerstört die us bundesrecht
im körper und kommt ihnen ungewollten
abwärtstrend und entsprechend lied mira
überbelastung ermüdungsbrüche
erschöpfungszustand und so weiter
[Musik]
in süditalien verzichten die beiden
singles auf das nachtleben
viele touristen würden sowieso nur
drogen und alkohol im kopf haben
beklagen die kraftsportler aber für
einen ferien flirt wären sie schon zu
haben
es bleibt beim reden über die frauen
die beiden sind sich auch sonst nicht
immer einig
nicht nur klasse
wir probieren alles mache das immer dann
mich immer noch lieben ich wollte nur
zeigen wie weit sich also dass er sein
muss aber nicht eingefallen musst und
bringt mir noch nie
bald findet der schönheitswettbewerb
stadt für den sie nun gang und posen
einstudiert sie darf dabei auf
unerwartete hilfe zählen miguel bieger
und jenny die pfeiler sind erneut ein
paar
was sicherlich passiert das wieder
zusammen sind durchs ganze dorf auf das
durchhaltevermögen einmal bin immer noch
krank sind die wichtigste für mich und
ich gebraucht habe
also mit dutzenden aber nachdem ich
verstehe das gut und es braucht ja
in seinem kinderzimmer hat alles an
rustam bene ein business gestartet nun
bietet auch er online fitness beratungen
an für maximal 350 franken mit wieder
über 100 liter benzin wo versuchen so
gut wie möglich zahl von mineral fällig
also ich versuche jetzt unterhalb von
der nähe kennen wie das ganze ablaufen
ich sage ihnen immer ein experte bin ich
nicht aber ich glaube durch ja das ist
alles der sachsler ermittler wir nicht
insgesamt sport noch über einen
leistungsbereich kann ich das ich
innerhalb der wahl kaufen
mit erfolg bis jetzt
[Musik]
bühne frei für definierte muskeln unter
falscher bräune
monatelang hat jenny für den
schönheitswettbewerb trainiert aber
jetzt wird ihr alles zu viel
es tue ihr angebot und finden das
schärfste
denn
ihr ziel elf kilo abzunehmen hat jenny
die schwelle erreicht
sie liegt jetzt noch 51 kilo bei einer
größe von einem meter 60 aber auch ihre
konkurrenz in der kategorie war die
fitness hat sich ins zeug gelegt
ja
die rollos mitbekommt nicht schon bei
der ersten selektion scheidet die
22-jährige aus
bäume wurden in märchen kommen nicht von
mir verlangen dass man erste schau
trainingserfahrung verbundene und aprimo
schon dass zum 15 mal machen das maß
aller dinge erfüllen diese dame es lebe
der körper denn mehr zählt hier nicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]